Who is Tony Stark’s new AI Friday (voiced
by Kerry Condon) she plays Mike’s daughter
in law on Better Call Saul. The FRiday character
debuted During the Iron Man Protocols storyline
in 2009. Pepper Potts stopped being Tony Stark’s
secretary, and instead of hiring a new one,
he decided to create one. His own Girl Friday.
The name is a play on the 1940s Cary Grant
movie called His Girl Friday where he plays
a newspaper editor trying to keep his ex-wife
from re-marrying because he’s still in love
with her.
So you get the joke. You could make all kinds
of shipping jokes about Tony being in love
with his AIs like JARVIS. In the comics it
was a pepper potts joke, But the movie turns
it into part of this larger Jocasta Easter
Egg.
Jocasta is His Girl Friday who Tony Stark
is trying to keep from marrying Ultron.
In the comics Ultron creates a new AI called
Jocasta to be his perfect Bride. The character
Jocasta is named after the greek tragedy of
Oedipus. The guy that ended up marrying his
mother, there are many levels to this. Which
is why Joss Whedon and Comic Book writers
are so much fun to follow.
Ultron built Jocasta using the brain patterns
of the Wasp, Janet Van Dyne. Ultron named
her Jocasta after the wife of Oediups because
Janet Van Dyne was kind of his mother. In
the comics, Ultron was created by Hank Pym
who was married to Janet Van Dyne. So Ultron
created his bride in his mother’s image.
Yikes.
Just like with Vision turning against Ultron,
Jocasta did too and she joined the Avengers.
I might have to do a bonus video for her at
some point because she has her own wierd history
in the comics.
There was even a time when Jarvis caught her
kissing hank pym in mighty avengers. That
was the storyline where Ultron takes over
Tony Stark’s extremis armor and creates
a female body for himself.
I know you guys are wondering if they’d
ever do Jocasta in the movies. It’s possible
Ultron will be back in some form for Infinity
War, but I’m not expecting it. Think about
how long the Red Skull has been MIA.
Who are the new characters?
Helen Cho is a character created by Greg Pak.
The same Greg Pak that wrote Planet Hulk.
She debuted in Incredible Hercules and was
the mother of Amadeus Cho. In the comics,
she existed only to serve the development
of the Amadeus Cho character. She was killed
off pretty quickly after Amadeus started partnering
up with Hercules. So the movie is changing
her backstory.
Because she’s so young in the movie, if
they do bring Amadeus Cho into the MCU, it
would have to be as her brother.
She’s in love with Thor in the movie, so
wouldn’t it be crazy if Amadeus Cho became
the son of Thor and Helen Cho?
The movie kind of gives her some aspects of
the Amadeus character. In the comics, Amadeus
is the 7th smartest person on the planet.
In the movie, Helen Cho is a genius biochemical
engineer that creates the synthetic skin Ultron
uses to 3D print Vision.
I’ll explain the Vibranium before I explain
Ulysses Klaw. They kind of go hand in Black
Panther hand.
Ultron bonds the Vibranium molecules with
Helen Cho’s synthetic skin technology to
form Vision’s body. The frisbee joke was
so good. The Most versatile substance on earth,
and the humans use it to make a frisbee. Talking
about Captain America’s shield.
The reason Vision is able to alter his form
is because he can control the bonded vibranium
synthetic skin can be reprogrammed as he sees
fit.
As for the flying, they don’t fully explain
how his repulsor technology works in the movie.
But blanket movie logic explanation is that
the vibranium based technology is a more advanced
form of Stark Tech. So think of Vision as
a hyper advanced Iron Man suit combined with
AI.
The mind gem is the reason he has a soul.
Even though you’d think it would be the
soul gem to do that.
His consciousness is built on the framework
of Ultron’s Chitauri programming combined
with JARVIS and the Mind Gem.
So if they removed the Mind Gem, it might
kill him. He’d probably start acting more
like Ultron. Which might end up happening
when Thanos eventually takes the gem to form
the infinity gauntlet.
I already did a video explaining a lot of
the Vision’s backstory in my TOP 5 Ultron
stories video. So I’ll add a link to that
in the description.
Fun Times with Vibranium Life Forms. Now Ulysses
Klaw, huge Black Panther villain. Andy Serkis,
most definitely going to reappear in the Black
Panther solo film.
The movie kind of tells the origin story of
Ulysses Klaw in the comics. He tries to steal
a bunch of Wakanda’s vibranium. Gets away
with a little, but winds up being branded
as a thief and mortal enemy of their people.
That’s what the tattoo was. Thats part of
Klaw’s origin story, so if you picked up
the John Romita Jr 2005 Black Panther title.
You can read that story. That’s one way
in which Marvel is getting rid of origin stories
in the movies.
So when we get to the black panther solo film.
They won’t have to explain Klaw’s entire
life history.
In the comics he has a mechanical hand. In
the movie Ultron gives him billions of dollars
for the vibranium, then cuts his hand off.
So Klaw has the resources to make himself
a new hand. Probably out of vibranium. That
we’ll probably get to see in the Black Panther
movie.
Doctor List we met on Agents of SHIELD this
week. He’s one of the current heads of HYDRA,
even though he winds up dead along with Baron
Von Strucker.
The next big head of HYDRA we’ll probably
meet is Baron Zemo in Captain America Civil
War. HYDRA has been getting the shit kicked
out of it for the last year, but they’re
still very much a thing in
the movies.
Hawkeye and Hulk’s role in the film are
at odds. Their story addresses one of the
moral cores of the film. Do Avengers get to
have normal lives? Bruce has that line where
he says, I don’t get to have this, talking
about Hawkeye’s secret but suprisingly normal
family. Hawkeye returns to them at the end
of the film. So the takeaway is that they
can have normal lives, but only when they’re
ready to stop being Avengers.
Hawkeye only returns because it’s his ‘one
last mission’.
Funny Side Note, Jeremy Renner still has movies
on his marvel contract. So
this isn’t the last time you’ll see hawkeye
in
a movie. He’ll probably cameo in Civil War.
But he won’t be an Avengers.
The new Avengers as of the end of
the film are:
Captain America leading, Vision, Scarlet Witch,
who will
probably hook up at some point, Falcon and
Black Widow.
I added links for some specific Black Panther
and Phase 3 movie videos like Thor Ragnarok.
So you
can jump around in my Marvel avengers playlist
if you want to check those out.